triple to lack inst it's instant divorce
it allows Muslim men to immediately
terminate a marriage just by repeating
the word to lack which means divorce in
Arabic three times to their wives the
words can be uttered either in person or
online and the woman has no recourse you
can't be like no aunt italic some Muslim
women say they have even been divorced
via whatsapp imagine no explanation just
you get the text Oh who's this - like -
like - like I'll [ __ ] I'm divorce
instantly like it's a [ __ ] wrestling
move by the way oh [ __ ] Razor Ramon
with the triple to lack oh the
beginnings of a triple to lack oh he
divorces with the pone he the boy he
divorced his [ __ ] spine from his head
in India Supreme Court ruled in August
2017 that triple toe Lac was
unconstitutional hey this [ __ ] divorcing
somebody by saying a word three times
like it's a beetlejuice imagine being
like you [ __ ] up the laundry again -
like - like - luck look I'm just saying
if you [ __ ] do that again you're
getting the triple - laughs that's all
dude when I [ __ ] read that I laughed
so hard I was crying I want to get
married just to do the triple to lack
and then have my [ __ ] American girl
just be like mm-hmm
are you [ __ ] out of your mind I mean
Jesus Christ you know this [ __ ] world
dude you got [ __ ] Suge Knight in jail
and every and Indian guys are [ __ ] -
lacking all day long